last part of this so in this lecture I
will talk about lower bounds for general
extended formulations and in particular
the lower bounds that I'll talk about
are reductions from so from so if you
take a share a leeadams gap or a CSP
let's say maxcut or CSP you get a cement
MP external formulation lower bound and
if you take sum of squares gap gap
instance you use that to construct nice
DPX and formulation lower bound and this
is what we're trying to do now but
before we talk about extant formations
directly let's let's let's look at
something different something seemingly
I know not very directly related but if
it's an interesting question so let's
just look at it and we'll use this in
the proof later and so the idea would be
that I will not be I may not be able to
get through all the technical details as
a proof and maybe all of them are not
important so I'll try to get to the main
conceptual details of the proof and the
main ideas in the so but let's look at
it so let's directly look at the look at
one question here so imagine you have a
probability distribution F on the
hypercube okay you have a probability
distribution on the hypercube and this
probability distribution is you know
it's normalized it as a density so
expectation of F is 1 so if it was the
uniform distribution it would be 1
everywhere
but it's not uniform distribution it's
non-uniform so it's higher at some
places lower at some places we will
bound the infinity norm of F by two to
the T okay think of T as a small number
okay and what you want to what you also
have is you have a family of tests like
think of these as a statistical test or
these are we can think of this is just
as functions for instance D 1 to D and
all the hypercube and your goal is to
your goal is to sort of construct an
approximation for F
against these tests
so what do I mean you want an
approximate er F tilde make sure you
have the right notation
so we want an approximate or F tilde so
what in what sense is it an approximate
err if you take any of the test if you
take a D di and if you take inner
product with di that's close to what it
would be
with the original function so f tilde is
an approximation for f in the sense that
on all these tests the value of the
function or the value of the test is
within a plus or minus ETA of the action
value and of course you would want F
tilde to be also a distant density right
you would want F tilde to be a density
[Music]
and of course we already had F at hand
why do we want F tilde we want F tilde
because hopefully f tilde is simpler
than F F tilde is something we
understand before he says F tilde could
be a hunter F tilde is hopefully simpler
so you know it could be simpler in
various ways it could be a hunter it
could be a low degree function and it
could be anything but maybe a sense if
you want a simpler object F tilde that
you want to work with which is as good
as f with respect to these tests that's
the goal this is a very natural question
and so a priori you know before I would
for me at least to the revelation that a
pair you think that there's no good
approximation because you know I'm just
starting with an arbitrary function f ok
how good can what what approximation can
I get which is better than f because
just an arbitrary function f but one
fact which sort of is a very revealing
to me is that this is a recurring fact
in it's like a meta observation I guess
is that if you want try to approximate
something the complexity of the
approximator only depends on the
complexity of the tests that you're
trying to fool not on the complexity
object so you can take any function of
any degree but if you want to
approximate it against degree D tests
you're approximator will be degree D so
so the complexity of the approximator
this is like a you know slightly meta
observation is is related to the
complexity of the test that you're
trying to fool not the object that
you're trying to approximate yes Capital
n oh this are the number of tests let's
assume that we have like a sequence of
tests possibly infinite number of tests
if you have a sequence of possibly
infinite number of tests that we care
about and we have a function f and the
one thing that's true is that in many
situations in completely in complexity
of this happens quite often that when
you try to approximate an object the
complexity of the approximate actually
depends on the complexity test that
you're trying to fool rather than the
complexity of the object itself which
this is very obvious if I say di is all
low degree functions suppose I say di is
all low degree functions
now f could be arbitrary degree right
what would you do for and I didn't care
that if we if tilde is a density right
you just project F to the load span of
the low degree functions it will
preserve the inner products with low
degree functions and so you give me any
function at this projected on to degree
D span that'll be the approximate ur you
see that the degree of the approximator
depends on the degree of the tests not
on the original function ok and so the
so this is what's going to be very
useful for us so let me just state what
we can prove here and see how we can
show you how I can prove it so in this
case we want to density so but this is
the theorem that we can prove there
exists an approximate ur F tilde
which is a density
such that for every test function for
every di in d di in a product F is
within plus or minus ETA of di in a
product l de yes look yeah so it the the
you yeah we'll come get it yes so as I
said the complexity of till it depends
on the complexity of D is and the
complexity of the ice is what good so f
tilde is not more complicated than the
tests in the following sense F tilde is
of the form
you take a bunch of dice
you add them up possibly with
coefficients and then you raise it to
the exponential so that's if if today is
looks like that it's exponential of a
bunch of sum of a bunch of D is how many
of the D is are you going to add add you
are going to add at most
I can use capital T
II log
a times the infinity norm of D divided
by epsilon squared I should say max
infinity norm but you significant out
already ice
so the function looks like a
normalization factor times an
exponential of a of a bunch of D is
exponential some of Burnsville yeah and
the number of D I see uses this much oh
sorry I should eat making mistake sorry
Thanks yeah this is ETA square
well okay so let's see so firstly it
does have depend on f in the sense that
it depends on the entropy of the main
entropy of F but just that but nothing
else in you know in particular F could
be a crazy function whereas this is a
very nice function so let's see why this
is nice before we go to the proof of
this so so imagine she let me add a page
okay so imagine if so here's a corollary
right so if your tests were home to us
let's say D is our M haunt us for some
em they depend on a small number of
variables what can you say about the
approximator right you let's say you
have all M mudras okay every possible
enter their exposure many of them you
would imagine that the approximate are
also depends on or every variable but
actually know the approximator only
depends on a you know T the infinity
norm of D by ETA squared times M
koonta because you you just added a
small number of D ice right you the the
way I think of it I think of capital T
as a small number of the ice because you
have a sufficiently high entropy
distribution F that T is really small
then so you're writing just a small
number of D ice and you have this
approximator which looks like an
expansion of a small number of D ice but
already it's sort of a very nice hunter
but it's an approximation for F which
was not at all a hunter which has an
arbitrary function
'is that yeah yes oh well the the
approximator F tilde depends on F all
I'm saying is that the complexity of the
approximator meaning in this case there
are coefficients on the di sorry yeah so
it's of course sorry the the approximate
it depends on the f you're trying to
approximate
but the whatever science is the
complexity of how complicated you think
the approximate is doesn't depend on how
complicated f is f could be a very
complicated function but the approximate
is going to be very simple because
you're trying to fool a set of simple
tests and that's what happens here
so you try for trying to fool only
hunters then your approximate er is
going to be hunter
Oh
yes sorry yeah thanks
so this is a yes are you gonna say
something about how this yeah of course
yes yes yeah yeah we'll just use this as
in the lower bound and we will use this
results but I just wanted to show this
thing first because it it's sort of the
main conceptual thing which I learned
from this paper and so another fact
which is also true is if each di right
is if the let's say di is a low degree
polynomial degree of di is let's say D
then what what happens to the degree how
does EV tilde look like f tilde looks
like this thing right it looks like this
exponential then
I think I should put an eater there but
it looks like an exponential in some of
them right so you can do Taylor series
expansion on this you can expand this in
Taylor series and truncate so you could
write it could take F F tilde of X and
then you could expand a key to the minus
X in terms of trade Taylor series now e
to the Z is 1 plus Z plus Z squared over
2 factorial and so on and then you can
truncate it you can get a low degree
approximation for F tilde right you can
truncate F tilde to get a low degree
polynomial and in particular F tilde you
can get is close to degree you know D
times whatever this quantity was T times
norm D infinity squared M by ETA squared
plus the square of
you need this polynomial
where is em oh oh sorry it's deep
they use d2 rhymes yeah I should just
have D once but but you know then we're
not going to see why this I want to be
important what the actual number is here
it's just that you know you take DI if
it's a degree D polynomial substitute
here expand out you truncate the Taylor
series at you get a truncated at a
certain degree and then you get a low
degree approximation but you know low
degree approximations we're not so
interesting as I saw earlier but what
you actually can get is a load square of
a low degree for long the reason is
because you know instead of I can write
f tilde is e to the something I can
write it as e to the so f tilde is e to
the Z so I can write it as e to the Z
over 2 whole square and then I can
approximate e to the Z over 2 I can
truncate inside the square so I get a
square of a low degree polynomial this
way so I am able to approximate density
by a square of a low degree polynomial
as long as all I care about our tests
which are low degree
yeah I think I might all my all my
glasses yes you can you can pick the
same eater and then you get the same
with this answer yeah any other
yes this is exactly the so how do you
get this let's see how you get this via
this theorem so the so you could do it
in a couple of ways one way to do it is
to say the so the way I like to do it is
to serve do it algorithmically you could
you could construct this approximation
algorithm weekly using multiplicative
weights or mirror descent okay so what
do you do so I want to approximate this
function f okay
so you
so you start with an approximation right
you here's the algorithm let you say
okay let's initialize like f tilde to be
the constant function so you start with
the uniform distribution as your
approximation so that's like the center
of the simplex so this is the simple two
to the n dimensional simplex which
contains all densities on 0 1 to the N
and then what I am doing is I start with
the center of the simplex which is just
the uniform distribution on 2 on 0 1 to
the N ok and at at any point in time
what you do is you see if if you
actually fool all the tests that you see
if there exists some test that you
didn't fool if they if they exist at SDI
such that F in a product D I is not is
very different from F tilde in a product
D I so
let's say it's let's say it's you know
greater or lesser then it's much greater
than f2f in a product di plus ETA or the
other way round the point is you find a
test that you don't fool when you find a
test that you don't fool you update your
distribution multiplicatively you say my
new F tilde is going to be my old F
tilde times e to the minus e to the ETA
times di of X that you use the test to
update your distribution find a
multiplicative fashion this is just
multiplicative weights update method or
mirror descent method I mean the in some
sense like this is very much the same as
gradient descent except that you know we
want to stay in the world of densities
like we want to have a approximator to
be a density and therefore you would
want to move in the simplex and you not
to move in the simplex this is the
correct way to update if you want to
move simply that's the fastest way to
move on the simplex so and the key is
that whenever you do this gradient
descent update where you actually move
closer to F in KL divergence okay so at
each step
what happens is the KL divergence to f
KL divergence to the distribution f of F
tilde and F decreases by
it's it's a basically at each step your
KL divergence decreases so in some sense
basically all I'm saying is you're in
this space and each time you see some
see that you the function f tilde and FD
are different on a test you update and
you learn something new you actually get
closer to F because you now actually
move in that direction so therefore but
you can't go on for too long the
distance you can go is exactly the KL
divergence from F to your original point
which is uniform distribution which we
assumed is at most T the KL divergence
between uniform distribution and F was
at most e so that's that's the reason
why you stop wake you converging T times
the infinity norm of D by epsilon square
any questions on this
an alternate way to sort of get get at
this is to say each of these constraints
on the approximator is a linear
constraint so you have a linear program
and you know the linear program is
feasible because you could just say F
tilde is equal to F and F is always a
good approximator for F but you want the
simplest such approximator so you solve
the max entropy this you find the
maximum entropy F tilde that satisfies
these linear constraints it's an
alternate way to do it if you do it
algorithmically the advantages you
actually know the number of updates
you're going to make and you you can get
the Hunter theorem out of it any any
questions on this okay so this is a one
of the main ingredients we're going to
use in our lower bound for the
correlation polytope and before I
actually go to the correlation polytope
I want to say that there's an analogous
thing for matrix valued functions so
what happened so far is that we had a
probability distribution F and we
approximated it by by an exponential
instead of a probability distribution
imagine you have a function Q which is
your function Q which is
maybe a little bit lost art again so
everybody's happy okay so listen Lee
this year will happen but yeah okay so
let's so just to sort of see what tell
you where the notation see instead of
you had a function f which was
non-negative on the hyper cube this is a
probability distribution instead now
what you have is a function that outputs
PSD matrices on the hyped on the hyper
cube right it's an R it's a function it
outputs a matrix which is always PSD so
Q is a function it's a matrix valued
function there are puts PSD matrices and
it's sort of normalized in the sense
that expected trace of Q is identity is
1 and then you have a bunch of tests but
now all the tests are matrix value tests
so you have a matrix valued function di
which is also outputs in R cross R
matrix right and then the test is just o
is
you do this this is that there's a
person what you want is your
approximator should match the test
within an error of ETA okay that's what
that's the same it's the same setup
except that you know instead of numbers
you're getting PSD matrices that's the
essentially the same thing and you can
run matrix multiplicative weights update
and you get an exponential approximation
you exponential Q tilde will have a form
which looks like exponential minus di
and then you can do the thing that we
said earlier you can expand you can
expand the Taylor series of the
exponential function to get a low degree
square so so the final theorem is that
you can actually find a low degree
matrix valued function whose square
approximates Q so we are able to
approximate an arbitrary PhD valued
function by the square of a low degree
matrix valued function that's the no
there is no dependence
essentially because yeah because a
spectral norm of Q is to the T and the
expectation is once it's so so it's the
very analogous thing will the MIT matrix
multiplicative weights update you have a
KL divergence you know the the the the
quantum version of that and you measure
progress with respect to certain you
it's really it's very analogous and
there's nothing very different that goes
on here and after you get the
exponential you truncate it by using
Taylor series and has the same
approximation so yes
a little D so if di is a sequence of
degree D tests then the degree of the
polynomial R is going to be this so you
see that one thing I should add is that
of course the degree of your or the
complexity of the degree of your
approximator actually is good in the
sense that it doesn't depend too much on
the original function Q but it is still
larger than the complexity of the test
you're trying to full degree D functions
you're going to not going to get degree
D s degree D approximately but something
slightly larger okay so okay so this was
a main this is going to be the main
ingredient I think now we are sort of
ready to do the proof except when we try
to prove lower bounds for general
extended formulations the first thing
you have to deal with is okay so what is
the general information you have a slack
matrix
no way this is stopped working or
together
[Music]
this is really bad okay it's fine so
let's try to use the board and use this
as sort of a marker so okay so okay so
now what we're trying to do we're trying
to prove lower bots for general extended
formulations okay so so we have you know
our original setup right here so this is
the so you see you so you have a slack
matrix it's written as non-negative
factorization where or a PSD
factorization if it's a non-negative
factorization P sub Z and Q sub X are
non-negative vectors of dimension R and
if it's a PSD factorization their phd
matrices of dimension R ok the first
thing that we want to prove prove that
such thing doesn't take this the first
thing that we need to worry about is how
large are these numbers P sub Z and Q
sub X that can PSD factorizations and
non-negative factorizations have
arbitrarily large numbers in fact even
if you want to do a counting argument it
you need to know how larger the number
is involved here in a non-negative
factorization note that the numbers in
the slack matrix itself are bounded
let's say we know the numbers they're
like 1 or something less than 1 but we
don't know anything about these numbers
piece of junk you survived it could be
arbitrarily large and the and the key
thing which is which we'll use is that
you can actually rescale these
factorizations so that the numbers are
nice so in the LP case the fact
rescaling is really easy because all it
was done earlier but in the SDP case the
work by braid
dedushka cooter and one I state here is
by fuzzy Juvia per your Robinson Thomas
gives you the right tree scaling so what
does this theorem say suppose you have a
matrix M which has a phd factorization
of rank R okay and let's say the matrix
M has small entries is a boundary
one what can we say about the entries of
these matrices P's and Q's it says that
if you take the essentially the spectral
norm of P and Q it's at most R so you
never need to use very large numbers and
this and what does this bias this biases
the fact that now we can actually do
some truncation and force the numbers to
be small refers the numbers to be small
and it it also means that we only give
area about bounded functions throughout
it throughout the rest of that talk the
functions that we care about they are
all bounded and that will be useful in
our approximation when we said that
their numbers are bound by two to the T
and so on it was very important that
okay so now we are good shape we can
actually start looking at the proof
don't think my pen has come back
for the whiteboards oh yeah that's Frank
oh thanks that's fantastic that's
fantastic yeah
so okay so here's their approach again
we will use lower bounds for sherilee
items or some squares in this the rest
of the talk I will actually be sort of
mixing up solid items and sum of squares
mainly because the proofs are going to
be very similar and so I won't really so
but but you know well let's see for
completeness let's say Sheryl Adams so
you start with an integral to GAAP
instance for Sheryl Adams just like we
did for the symmetric case you have a
integrate Gap instance like a graph or
something as small so it gives you a
function that's not the sum of non-nato
Kunduz okay and from that so that's an
instance of size M right so it's it's a
fixed size instance think of this as an
integrator gap instance on a thousand
vertices or something okay and from that
we actually construct a family of hard
instances well what are these well it's
just you have n words you have n
variables right x1 through xn and you
have a function that only depends on M
variables M is like a thousand or
something so this hard function family
of heart functions literally just
consists of planting this function on
arbitrary subsets so sigh of size of s
of X is just you take P of X of s for
every subset you get we get one such
function and all each every one of these
functions is a heart function for
sherilee items because just took the
same function planted in different
places but it's going to be useful that
we have all of these together
suppose the correlation polytope has a
small extended formulation let's a small
linear programming formulation so
suppose then there is a you know we saw
that every fictional formulation has a
family of functions associated with it
which is we called it f there are are
functions so these are let's say
non-negative functions on the hypercube
so you have a family of functions on the
hypercube that can express every every
thing in particular it can I also
express these hard instances so what
what is true is that H is in the cone it
is in the cone of F right cone generated
by F this is a clearly true now the so
the idea is we're going to be very
simple we are going to approximate this
additional advantage I can keep going
down it may be you know tria okay so the
idea is we're going to approximate each
fi by a hunter and then that will imply
that H is in the cone of non negative
hunters
which is a contradiction a contradiction
because it consists of it has the H
consists of surely Adams gap instances
so that's the basic idea if you just the
the whole point of the approximation
theorem that we talked about is that a
general linear program consists of a
general family of functions and what
we'll do is we'll approximate this
general family of functions by hunters
and so then if you're if you can express
H using the general family Fox you can
also express using hunters and then unit
trouble okay okay
so the key notion here is what how good
should the approximation be
now I realize the one disadvantage with
this is that over here it gets a raise
when I go to the next page stays here
okay that's fine okay
so how good should this approximation be
so so let's go back and look at our hard
instances and just understand them a
little bit more so you have the cone of
non- holders is a cone of non negative
hunters and fee is a hard instance for
sherilee items so it sits outside the
cone not just fee but every possible
size of s all of them sit outside the
cone okay let's just fix the size look
at size of s it sits outside the cone
okay so what is the space this is the
space of all functions
on the hypercube and then you have this
cone of non- hunters there and this is
lizard God what that means is there is a
separator that separates the two and the
separator is going to be this some other
function D D sub s such that if on this
side the inner product with G sub s is
less than minus Epsilon
on this side the inner product with D
sub s is more than zero so there's a
distinguisher that separates my share
Aladdin's gap from non-negative hunters
now all I need is that my approximator
fools this distinguisher
if the if the approximator fools this
distinguisher then we are in good shape
but before we get ahead of ourselves let
let me just so if you look at this
picture there's one more thing a couple
of things you need to observe is that
you know if you are separating from the
cone of non- hunters right here this
distinguishes separates them d itself is
a hunter in the in the sense that it
depends on only M coordinates
this is sort of clear because you know
our function sigh depends on M
coordinates right and so you're really
talking about functions on M bits some
subset of M bits but really some subset
of M bits and therefore you're really
not working on all functions in 0 1 to
the N you can think of this as happening
in the space of functions on 0 1 to the
s and therefore it's really this
distinguisher only depends on m
coordinates so distinguisher is like a
hunter and that was sort of the we are
going to exploit that in the sense that
we are distinguishers like our gap
instances are local right this is only
depends I'm currents are distinguishes
are also local like they only depend on
M corners and the corresponding thing in
SOS will be our distinguisher will be
low degree V sub s is low degree in the
but you know please ignore this thing if
it is too much no ok so this is a thing
ok so now the claim is if
okay so if we take each of these
functions Fi and if we approximate it by
a beholder let's say fi non-negative
behold us so let's let's do it this is
suppose the approximator fi tilde for fi
is a d Hunta suppose we get a d hunter
that approximates fi okay then what do
we know well because it's an approximate
er we know that on every distinguisher
it has a sum the same value that's of
course this because an approximator
and then because this is a d hunter you
know that d sub s is none is non
negative there if you give it a hunter
it gives you a positive number so if you
give this ebbesson
volta this gives you a positive number a
d hunter gives a positive so what this
shows is that it's showing that all the
F is live on this side of the hyperplane
if you could approximate each fi by a D
hunter then even the FI is live on this
side of the hyperplane
all their files live on this era
hyperplane then of course the corn of F
ice will not contain this yes
right so so this epsilon is something
that you get from the original Gap
instance right so the original this
whole picture was for the original Gap
instance where this is a gap is
officially added up so it's away from
the cone of non- HOTAS so it since you
start with a fixed gap instance you
can't even assume it to be a constant
and in many cases you can just asymmetry
or here's a bit to be a constant note
that yeah because we start with the
fixed gap instance for sure Adams is
really a constant separation that we can
use okay so this is a that would be the
proof if we got if HFI to be a d Hunta
we would be done if so each fi till that
will be d Hunta we'd be done but of
course this is too good to hope for
because we already saw that the complex
is approximate is actually more
complicated than the distribution so
what we get is actually that each fi
tilde is from the approximation theorem
we get that each fi tilde is as larger
hunter it's um you know it's it's
something much larger a sec you know M
times T over ETA squared it's a much
larger root but it's still a hundred so
so this is where we are going to use so
so so requires a larger hunter this fact
is no longer true this fact is no longer
true because da D sub s only separates
the corner of D hunters
okay but why does this not a problem
well it's not a problem because of the
following reason imagine picking a
subset s at random like pick a random
planting so we have this picture so s is
picked at random yeah so if I tilde is
some hunter right in some hunter which
is know if this number is looks
complicated think of it as like root N
or something
there's something much smaller than n
you say your F F so you have you
constructed an approximator for each of
their face which is like a root n hunter
so each fi now depends on a subset of
size root n it's a root and volta that's
what each fi Tilda does but now what you
do is you pick a subset s at random and
you look at just feasible size of s
consider size of s now firstly how many
look at any fixed Fi it for a fixed fi I
for a fixed I look at fi tilde right it
depends on a subset of root n
coordinates
how many of these coordinates fall
inside the subsidiary care about
actually what you expect is you know
this is a set of size M the set asides
root N or something so it's like less
than M over root n the expected size is
M over root N and it's in fact
concentrated so this is the probability
that the size is I could say the
probability that the intersection size
is more than T is like less than n to
the - let's say 0.1 T so so so we
approximate each fi by a root n hunter
but then now if I look at a random
instance a random instance chosen here
restricted to these variables these are
much stronger hunters you can apply
Union bound over all the functions and
say that if you have only n to the T if
you have if there exists if the size of
the family is smaller than n to the 0.1
t then there's a good chance that all of
them are T d hunters then let's say if I
use D here into the point twenty then
restricted to the set that you chose all
fi Rd hunters
so this is where random restriction is
showing up this is like the random
restriction step oh sorry all fi tilde D
holders yes all fi tilde Rd hunters
restricted to that and that means that
when you do this calculation you say D
sub s into profiles go to this okay and
then you say oh look at this inner
product what is this inner product
really it is inner products really
expectation or X D sub s of X F I tilde
of X okay right and but you know
d sub s only depends on X sub s so I can
average out the coordinates outside X
sub s so I can take away the dependence
on if I tilde on the remaining
coordinates so basically all I'm saying
is this is equal to inner product of D
sub s times the expectation where you
average out the outside coordinates and
so this is actually a hunter whose
hunters which only depends on the
intersecting coordinates which is s
intersections here and is a good hunter
is a be hunter so that's why random
restriction shows up now it seems like
random restriction is very crucial here
and it's not just I feel like it's not
just crucial here it's crucial in May I
think maybe half the proofs in
complexity theory that's what is going
on that you have to lower bounds
incompletions you have lower complexity
that's what is going on that you really
need a dimension the same happens in
proof complexity in circuit complexity
it's really important that you you have
this symmetry the key thing that we are
using is the fact that the set of
instances that we start with which is
the set of all graphs has this symmetry
even though the polytope does not have
the symmetry the set of graphs have the
symmetry that I can plant my instance
anywhere I can make any subset of bits
relevant and this is sort of used in
parity lower bounds faces 0 and
everywhere so the random structure is
not a trick that we could get away with
here the learning itself you know maybe
it's not very crucial maybe there are
better ways to do it then than to do
learning ok so yes so the so the reason
ok so the one thing that you lose
because of a random restriction is that
you it's you can never get exponential
bounds you can get at most two to the N
to the 0.5 or something that's already
the that's already the case can all do
but
for in this proof we we lose lot more
than that because the thing that I had
was the infinity norm of the D s the
infinity norm of the distinguishing the
infinity norm of the distinguisher we
didn't care about it because we started
with a constant size gap in Stinson
but if you want to get a good lower-body
to serve the large gap instance and then
the infinity now of DA starts growing
very quickly so this low this particular
proof only gives you lower bounds of up
to size n to the log n doesn't give
better than in to the log n but it gives
you a strong theorem that among all LP
relaxations of size n to the D degree D
serve sum of squares gives you the among
all LP relaxations the degree D surely
atoms gives the best approximation
I'm call SDP relaxations degree D sum of
squares gives the best approximation for
roughly the same size but this only
works to link to the log n in a newer
work we get exponential lower bounds but
that is a yeah it's a different no it's
a different approach uses communication
complexity techniques like the ideas
inspired from communication complexity
but yeah I don't understand that
proof well enough to see works yes
you're still showing the same result for
beyond n to the log n still showing that
among degree D relaxations alongside it
elections of size n to the D Shelly Adam
says this is the optimal but the proof
itself is yeah it has a bunch of yeah
non-canonical not not not the first
thing you do this seems like most of the
things into are the first canonical
things you
try and I don't have to say anything
about that I talked about the summer LP
lower bound here but I don't think I
have to say anything about the SDP lower
bound because it's essentially the same
there's not much to say about the SDP
lower board because it is essentially
the same yeah yeah and I guess I should
state some open questions of course one
main one question is a matching polytope
does matching porter of a small sized
SDP extent formations another question
is if you just take max 3sat can you get
better than 7/8 using sub-exponential
size SDP formulations that's the same
question as push this results beyond n
to the log into 2 to the N for a CPS we
don't know how to do that
any questions so the question was can we
do the same formatting and know we tried
quite a bit it didn't work because the
Fourier analysis gets very messy on
matchings but so the reason is yeah I
guess you know we talked about degree D
functions on matchings and so on that
you should take the function space of
functions on matching and break it up
into different degrees then it's where
the projections on to low degree it's
it's the you don't get the because of
the just I guess the one thing
concretely that blows up is where you
had the infinity norm of the
distinguisher I don't you need a proof
that the Infinity no distinction is
small if you just use the trivial bound
on the Infinity norm of the
distinguisher it's really large and so
on yeah so the infinite even if you took
a degree three matching law lower bound
if you look at it on n vertices the
Infinity norm of the C which is n cube I
think or or it grows with n I guess
because this is one waste one conflict
issue is really the zero one to the NS
product structure so I can really place
a smaller instance inside a bigger
instance in matching you can't really
place a smaller instance anywhere
because the edges have to leave out
right every vertex needs to be paired in
every matching so if you just place a
small instance somewhere in most of the
matching zall they just would be leaving
out so it's a yeah yeah so I don't know
yeah what's the right way to do it
but yeah you think that just by letting
functions on matchings you should be
able to cone and somehow that's not I
mean that's talked about to compute
somehow oh yeah could could be as long
as we have all this convexity thing yeah
it these things might still work it's
really when we because we have convex
you still have the duality still have
the factorization theorem doesn't yeah I
could still for possibly prove it
sighs that's unclear what
they can have the dakotas otherwise
and even having finally confession
[Applause]